all plants are our brothers and sisters
they talk to us and if we listen we can
hear them
day and night cannot dwell together
it is better to have less thunder in the
mouth and more lightning in the hand
tell me and i'll forget show me and i
may not remember involve me and i'll
understand
[Music]
before eating always take time to thank
the food
be afraid to cry it will free your mind
of sorrowful thoughts
when we show our respect for other
living things they respond with respect
for us
[Music]
if we wonder often the gift of knowledge
will come
most of us do not look as handsome to
others as we do to ourselves
those that lie down with dogs get up
with fleas
in age talk in childhood tears
we always return to our first loves
when you were born you cried and the
world rejoiced live your life so that
when you die the world cries and you
rejoice
those who have one foot in the canoe and
one foot in the boat are going to fall
into the river
the weakness of the enemy makes our
strength
a good soldier is a poor scout
poverty is a news that strangles
humility and breeds disrespect for god
and man
[Music]
we will be known forever by the tracks
we leave
do not judge your neighbor until you
walk two moons in his moccasins
there is nothing as eloquent as a
rattlesnake's tail
force no matter how concealed begets
resistance
our first teacher is our own heart
everyone who is successful must have
dreamed of something
all who have died are equal
remember that your children are not your
own but are lent to you by the creator
one rain does not make a crop
man's law changes with his understanding
of man
only the laws of the spirit remain
always the same
what the people believe is true
you already possess everything necessary
to become great
there is no death only a change of
worlds
life is not separate from death it only
looks that way
[Music]
you can't wake a person who is
pretending to be asleep
it is less of a problem to be poor than
to be dishonest
one finger cannot lift a pebble
beware of the man who does not talk and
the dog that does not bark
[Music]
all dreams spin out from the same web
old age is not as honorable as death but
most people want it
even a small mouse has anger
if a man is as wise as a serpent he can
afford to be as harmless as a dove
the rainbow is a sign from him who is in
all things
walk lightly in the spring mother earth
is pregnant
[Music]
when a man moves away from nature his
heart becomes hard
[Music]
everything the power does it does in a
circle
a brave man dies but once a coward many
times
a man or woman with many children has
many homes
seek wisdom not knowledge knowledges of
the past wisdom is of the future
[Music]
if you see no reason for giving thanks
the fault lies in yourself
a good chief gives he does not take
coyote is always out there waiting and
coyote is always hungry
[Music]
listening to a liar is like drinking
warm water
every animal knows more than you do
to touch the earth is to have harmony
with nature
when a fox walks lame the old rabbit
jumps
many have fallen with the bottle in
their hand
a starving man will eat with a wolf
[Music]
a danger foreseen is half avoided
[Music]
the coward shoots with shut eyes
it is easy to be brave from a distance
the bird who has eaten cannot fly with a
bird that is hungry
ask questions from your heart and you
will be answered from the heart
[Music]
a hungry stomach makes a short prayer
do not wrong or hate your neighbor for
it is not he that you wronged but
yourself
make my enemy brave and strong so that
if defeated i will not be ashamed
[Music]
cherish youth but trust old age
sharing and giving are the ways of god
we are all one child spinning through
mother sky
each person is his own judge
we are made from mother earth and we go
back to mother earth
it is no longer good enough to cry peace
we must act peace live peace and live in
peace
[Music]
they are not dead who live in the hearts
they leave behind
[Music]
there are many good moccasin tracks
along the trail of a straight arrow
a rocky vineyard does not need a prayer
but a pickaxe
with all things and in all things we are
relatives
the one who tells the stories rules the
world
the frog does not drink up the pond in
which he lives
a people without a history is like the
wind over buffalo grass
the moon is not shamed by the barking of
dogs
white men have too many chiefs
if a man is to do something more than
human he must have more than human
powers
the soul would have no rainbow if the
eye had no tears
wisdom comes only when you stop looking
for it and start living the life the
creator intended for you
not every sweet root gives birth to
sweet grass
[Music]
take only what you need and leave the
land as you found it
[Music]
it takes a thousand voices to tell a
single story
don't let yesterday use up too much of
today
no river can return to its source yet
all rivers must have a beginning
listen or your tongue will make you deaf
[Music]
man has responsibility not power
the rain falls on the just and the
unjust
each bird loves to hear himself sing
the way of the troublemaker is thorny
god gives us each a song
a man must make his own arrows
after dark all cats are leopards
when you die you will be spoken of as
those in the sky like the stars
you